you wanted to ask about the concept of
beta tization through a thousand
concessions you sort of wanted to like
get some advice and feedback on your
marriage and that relationship and how
to make sure that it uh ensues in
perpetuity so um so what's working
what's not working like why the question
around the beta
tization um I think so far at the moment
everything so far is working and I want
to make sure that I'm doing what I can
to sustain of how it is working right
now everything's going well to where he
feels definitely like the man he is um
and when I came across the beta uh beta
tization by a Thousand Cuts um kind of
like how little words just little
Snippets that you come possibly
subconsciously from uh from a woman can
little by little just cut him down and
I'm kind of curious of what some
examples of those are and then hopefully
if I gain more understanding uh I can be
more aware of to where making sure I
don't get to that point
yeah so to sort of explain it to the
viewers that don't understand um Caitlyn
do you know what beta tization through a
thousand concessions is yes cool all
right so you so you got some frame on so
for those that are watching that don't
understand that part it's it's it's more
or less competency test that women use
on men to make sure that he's got
himself squared away that he's that he's
a good guy he's good he's a good man
he's good at being a man he can do what
he's expected of for her for the family
you know for the children it's done I
think almost all women do this and when
you see this you can't unsee it like
once you understand what it is then
you'll see it you'll see it when you're
out at the grocery store you'll see it
at family events you'll see it with uh
other couples that are together um
whether it's at an event dinner wedding
doesn't matter what it is but it pops up
and it's comes at the expense of his
masculinity right you know his you know
his position as a man because in today's
world we're
making terrible versions of uh men with
women and we're making terrible versions
of uh women out of men so women are
becoming more masculinized and men are
becoming more feminized right and these
tests and the example that I use in my
book is honey put the white socks in the
white hamper and put the dark socks in
the dark hamper and it's funny because I
had this conversation with uh Dan
katrick on her podcast and that was
probably one of my favorite
conversations I've had with a woman ever
on a podcast because she's so witty and
clever with the way that uh she
navigates a lot of this stuff and she
said in response to that well that just
makes sense like why would you do it any
other way and I think that that's like
the natural organized OCD you know
progression that women generally use and
the thing is is that if he's putting his
I mean we're just going to use socks as
an example player but if he's putting
his white socks and his dark socks and
his towels and his mixed colors and
whatever hamper he he wants and it gets
washed and it gets cleaned and put away
that's the way that he's always done it
and that's the way that he's always been
comfortable doing it and that's the way
that he's always organized his life and
then you blend lives and then you tend
to live together and you know it's like
oh well you know you can't brush your
teeth over there because you're going to
get toothpaste on the carpet sort of
thing the problem with the beta tization
is they're like little paper cuts they
don't hurt that much but you notice them
okay somebody notices them either he
notices them or you notice them the way
that he tends to notice them is like oh
that's annoying why is she nagging me he
usually takes it as like a nag and then
because he's been programmed with the
happy wife happy life narrative he just
goes along to get along okay fine I'll
put the white socks and the white hamper
and the dark socks and dark Amper I'll
not brush my teeth over there even
though it's something I've always done
right so these new introductions in his
life with new rules and guidelines that
you try to set to sort of organize him
um in some ways it's is almost mothering
him you know if you know what I mean
because like you know moms will try to
do this kind of stuff you know with
their children especially their boys
right um so it so it weakens his
position in the relationship it softens
him it makes him more compliant and
makes him more agreeable and ultimately
through a thousand of these little
concessions that you sort of run him
through he becomes less and less
attractive to you women don't do this I
think to make women sorry to make their
man less attractive they just do it
because it's ingrained in their hardwire
and their DNA and the fabric of who they
are as women to make sure that they're
with a competent guy they don't want to
be with an incompetent guy because you
go back 5,000 years if you had children
with a with a [__] it could spell
certain death for you and your children
if he was incompetent if he couldn't
bring home the food if he was unable to
protect you from Waring tribes and you
know stuff like that so the notion of of
of [__] testing him which is what like a
lot of guys call it now is you know they
get tested with these little things it
starts to pile up and it's like death by
a thousand paper cuts so to your
question of like how do I not do that
like how do I you know make sure that I
don't put him through beta
tization I've never thought about it
from this angle man what about you MF
have you thought about
this I think it's such an interesting
question because I think it really is
women like I'm going to get killed for
this I'm sure in the comments
but women a bad rep a lot of times when
it comes to this kind of stuff because
if you really understand where this type
of behavior comes from it's a feature
it's not a bug most of what drives our
behavior is the need for survival and so
to your point if you were to saddle up
or you were to marry or have kids with a
man that couldn't protect you couldn't
take care of you was not competent
couldn't get things done you essentially
were screwed um so there's there's an
incentive for you to
constantly reaffirm that this man is the
best you can do that he fulfills your
hypergamous narrative or imperative
which is the best guy that I can
possibly get for my survival and the
survival of my kids and so it's
it's it's the equivalent of asking a man
to not want to something as simple and
innate as wanting to spread seed like
it's Human Nature sure that we um have
these things
but can we should we override them and
it's it's this kind of really weird
internal battle um that I think Jessica
is kind of asking about and sort of
struggling with because a lot of times
you don't you probably don't even
realize you're doing it that's that's
the thing most women like they don't
even realize it you know it's something
that I tell guys to manage right it's I
think it's incumbent upon men to to take
on the burden of not going through beta
tization of not letting
her allow him to get pushed through that
so you know I'll use an example because
you know I've been with my gal for years
now right and she'll still do this
unknowingly like I am the unplugged
Alpha I wrote the [__] book on it
right like you know this is like the
conversations that I have all the time
right and it's like you know she'll
she'll say something along the lines of
um like I use a dish dishwasher as an
example we'll have a disagreement on the
loading of the dishwasher right there's
there's a a statement you know along the
lines of oh your machine doesn't uh wash
them as quickly as mine and this and
that I'm not going to load it because
you don't load it the way that I load it
and it's
like blah blah blah and I'm not saying
that to be you know disparaging it's
just she's a chick and she's GNA say
what you know she needs to say to sort
of get it off her her back she's
feminine let her do that she's cooking
the meals she's feeding me well and all
that sort of stuff it's like I don't
care right like I'll like I'll load the
dishwasher my way it's my dishwasher
I'll put in the puck I'm not right yeah
yeah well it comes out clean at the end
of the day but it's like you know it's
like back to the well do you put the
white socks in the white H hamper or do
you you know have like a secondary
hamper between the white hamper and the
dark hamper sort of thing and it's like
no I don't it's like who cares you know
like why is this even a debate or an
argument so so I don't think that you
entertain it like you don't give it
oxygen like as a guy I think it's a
guy's job not to give it oxygen not to
feed it because you know when you feed
these things and they tend to grow right
you know you can nod you know you can
you can acknowledge but you carry on
doing what what it is that you were
going to do anyway as a man which is put
put your socks in whichever hamper
you've always put it in because they'll
get cleaned anyway so what if they fade
so what if they turn you know slightly
off color if that's the way that you've
always done it who cares right like this
is not a debate that needs to happen I
also if it's a new thing it's it's
worrying it it's like a rocking chair it
gives you something to do but it'll take
you nowhere well you know I think from a
woman's perspective and you know ladies
you can chime in and sort of you know
enlighten me from your angle why does
it why do we have to make a mountain out
of a mole hill right like if you want to
do it a certain way
this is a mole hill it's not going to
break the day it doesn't like why do we
have to make a mountain out of a mole I
think is a question that women should be
asking themselves if I don't want to put
my man through beta tization through a
thousand concessions and find him less
attractive because at the end of the day
that's what happens like that's one of
the things that contributes to the
breakup of a of a relationship is the
guy's like yes fine okay yes yes yes
like Chris Rock has a bit in his standup
comedy where he's like just give her a
stamp that says yes yes yes yes and you
just stamp everything yes right and this
agreement to everything that you push on
him that you want him to do women don't
like agreeable men right like I think
that the ladies would agree like you
don't want them to say yes to everything
right agreed passive pass they don't
want passivity yeah you don't want yeah
like you don't want a yes man like you
want a guy with a backbone that stands
for something and in some cases it's
going to stand for things that that they
believe and that that they stand for
that you may not necessar neily agree
with right like how the dishwasher gets
loaded right like are like do we really
need to make a mountain out of a mole
hill on this subject sort of thing so
just sort of Nod your head as a guy and
just do what do whatever it was that you
were going to do anyway and that's how
you sort of go about your business with
it and not allow yourself to get beta
tized I really hope you guys enjoyed
that clip if you want to watch the full
length podcast you can find that over
here that clips from if you're new to
the channel make sure you hit subscribe
over here and pin down below in the top
comment you'll find a bunch of useful
links to my ite my supplement line books
and a bunch of other stuff have an
amazing day peace out